hey what's up on today's show we talked
to a 55 year old woman who is struggling
with an unhappy marriage
we talked to an awesome big brother
who's trying to figure out how to help
his struggling younger brother
and we talk with an awesome dad whose
son's getting married and he wants to
know how he can help them move back in
without causing chaos in a new marriage
stay tuned
hey what's up good folks this is delony
this is john with the dr john dolone
show
i sent my name backwards i don't even
know why i did that this is delony comma
john
with the dr john dolone show where i
take your calls about your life your
relationships your marriages that guy
you're dating
schools kids all of it right all of it
we talk about mental health challenges
family and relational iq
anything you can think of addiction
parenting all of it is right here
taking your calls about your life give
me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
and here's the thing i know
somebody is driving their car right now
listening to this
and things are real real hard
and i know that somebody is vacuuming
listening to this in their ear earbuds
or you're like me and you've got
headphones with cords still on them
because evidently that's so
old-fashioned and um
you're vacuuming and things are real
real hard
and some of you put on headphones
because your kid won't stop crying and
you just gotta block it out
and some of you are walking around the
neighborhood right now to avoid your
family
and i get it here's what i want i want
to
encourage you and challenge you it's
hard right now
the adrenaline of the election is
wearing off
the the exhaustion from kova just won't
stop
our kids are slowly getting some emails
around the country that school's gonna
kick back up
just in time for spring break and just
in time for
workplaces are figuring it out things
are hard and messy we've got a whole
bunch more decisions to make and i want
to encourage you
reach out and talk to somebody that you
love don't do life by yourself
shoot me send me one of the the
i think the kids call them the dms right
send me a direct message on instagram
shoot me an email
at ask john ramseysolutions.com
go to the show page johndaloni.comshow
fill out the form and i'd love to get
you out here but here's the thing don't
do life by yourself
and the final thing don't give up
don't give up and sometimes it's me
on this show there's the pot talking to
the kettle here take another step
in another step and another step life's
hard and it's
long and it's exhausting and sometimes
just flying out boring
but keep going find people to do it with
and i tell you what man there's a light
at the end of that tunnel and as my
friend dave says it's not a train
there's a light at the end of that
tunnel and it is peace people often ask
me like what is peace man what does that
do what is
here's what peace is peace is just
laying down at night and going to sleep
pieces finishing your dinner and looking
at your kids and
realizing i don't have to worry about i
don't have much extra bills
my wife and i are on the same page like
let's just go outside and play
peace is your wife saying hey
i just need some time by myself and you
smiling and going sweet we're gonna
we're gonna have a good time me and the
kids
or you go have fun i'm gonna go have fun
and then we'll circle back and there's
not any tension
not any is there a problem or things
where
that's what pieces man and so many of us
don't even know what that feels like
it's just a fantasy it's not even real
so here's what i want to encourage you
just take another step
take another step it's boring i know
take another step i'm exhausted
i know phone a friend
go see somebody and then take another
step
if i vacuum this floor one more time i
know i know take another
step and you know who i'm talking i'm
talking to you
you right now you just thought is he
talking to me yes i'm talking to you
and if this isn't you if this if you are
just doing awesome
if life is going really good for you
right now
take pause this podcast and then call
somebody
call somebody that you know isn't doing
well because they're going to surprise
you
they're going to be open to you and be
vulnerable with you they're going to let
you know some stuff is going on in their
heart mind and you're going to be that
person for them
so pause right now i'm probably the only
podcast in podcast history to tell
people to turn this off and go do
something else
turn it off and go call somebody then
you can always come back i'm not going
anywhere and i'm probably going to be
telling the same story when you get back
so just take all the time you want on
the phone call all right
so that's it so let's go right to the
phones today man let's just get to it
let's go to patty in cleveland ohio
patty my love what's going on how are we
doing i'm doing good thanks for taking
my call dr galoni thank you so so much
for calling how can i help
well i'd like to know what i can do um
to move forward progressively i caught
my husband having an online affair two
years ago and i'm still not over it
ah okay so walk me back to that moment
when you caught him what happened
well i think the holy spirit was urging
me to look in his laptop and i did
and right there it was and i screenshot
it all
confronted him with it and i thought we
were going we had just
reconciled after um three years of
separation
and he didn't deny it he says i don't
know what's wrong maybe i'm just having
a midlife crisis he ended up going to
a psychologist for a good
probably four months and then she
dropped him something came up in her
life and he never went back
i went to marriage counseling on my own
and she gave me some some tools you know
how to
work through it but i just that trust
has just been betrayed and i don't know
how to get it back
just i just don't know how so you were
separated from him
why are you all separated um
mental mental and physical abuse and
he's got a drinking problem okay
so you've got you're not psychologically
safe or you weren't
at it for a period of time you were not
um physically safe
and then you you left
you got back together and how long were
you together before you found out that
he was cheating on you
uh we were back together probably about
a year
18 months okay and this is all two years
ago so fast forward to now what's the
state of your relationship right now
um it's much more loving but i find
myself whenever we're in a public
situation
that i am very aware of who else is in
the
in the room in the establishment i
find myself watching him intently
taking everything he says directly to
heart and
not brushing it off especially if he
starts drinking
and i i just i'm getting to the point
where i just don't know how to deal with
it anymore
do you want to be in this relationship
yes
and that's that's part of the problem i
do want to be in this relationship
i'm 55 this is my second marriage his
fourth marriage
yeah but not failing is not a reason to
stay in an
unsafe abusive alcoholic cheating
marriage
oh he's yeah he's he has not done any of
the above
aforementioned since i i busted him okay
it's just i i can't seem to get over
that hump and
to let the trust come or not
and you know give him enough rope is he
going to hang himself
it's not the most encouraging analogy of
this guy
you're trying to rebuild with i'm going
to see if he'll just kill himself
not a super firm foundation to rekindle
a marriage on
here's the thing um kudos to you
right kudos to you patty for for owning
this
one of the biggest challenges in
relationships when when there's
infidelity when there is
a separation of any kind right a
violation of values
is this idea we're going to come back
together and then once we come back
together and you say i'm
all in i'm i am pushing all my cards on
the table
i'm all in back on you
then that means you are committing to
doing the work on your and too
to rebuild trust to
allow yourself to be trusted right
because you still don't trust patty
right to learn to trust him
and you're not doing that so you passed
my initial test which is do you even
want to be in this relationship anymore
why don't you just get out and move on
right and your answer to me was
because i'm 55 and this is two for me
and four for him
are you okay just being roommates and
riding this thing out
i that's kind of what we've been doing
um
why are you why are you why are you
settling for that
you're halfway done patty i know i know
i i think there's something more in the
horizon i think there's something that
that
that
i am meant to stay in this relationship
i have been praying and praying and
praying and i've asked i've asked
do i stay do i go do i divorce do i
what do i do and then i went through the
the ramsey solutions
and i started listening to your podcast
and well you know what i'm going to ask
him
so patty wins the last i do patty when's
the last time
you woke up early before he gets up
and he went and you went and cooked
something that he loves
and he came in all snotty and gross and
making old man noises
and you went up and grabbed his chin and
you looked in my eye and said
i love you i want you to know that
when's the last time that happened oh
i do that darn near every weekend i i'm
a day shift person here too but i get up
at 3 30 in the morning he doesn't get up
until 8. i start work at six he starts
at 8 30. so when's the last time
he got up before you made you breakfast
and looked you in the eye and said honey
i love you i'm so glad that you stuck
through my
stupidity and my heartbreak and my
addictions and my
problems and i'm so glad we're still
here
um i would say back when we first got
together because he doesn't think he's
got a problem
okay you told me he doesn't anymore and
i trust you
i don't believe you but i trust you
those aren't two things he doesn't think
he's got a problem um he's gotten
he's maintained uh there's no more abuse
um the drinking has gone down to minimal
um you
you don't want to let this go
no and i'm asking you why
because i love him no no no not the
relationship
why won't you let go of the
just the sandbags you're carrying around
from the last five six seven years
why won't you just let it put it down
and head off into tomorrow
hmm good question i've tried that i
actually have tried to just let it go
and move forward
no no you it's not it's not an ethereal
thing it's not an ethereal thing it's
not something that you just declare like
that one office episode where michael
scott comes out and he's like i declare
bankruptcy it's like that's not how that
works there's a lot of forms
there's seven years you get right it's a
lot of stuff
but there's something about you that is
hanging on to that past
and here's the thing it's not weird that
you are
you were hurt in a lot of different ways
you were married to somebody who was an
alcoholic those are hard hard
relationships because
those are disconnection issues that's
hard you've been through the trauma
there's a part of your brain that is
protecting you 24 7 from this guy
right yeah and there's the other part of
you that says i love him
i'm gonna ride or die with this dude for
as many years as i got left i'm 55 so
i'm about halfway done
right because you're going to live to be
110 clevelanders just live forever
right i don't know if that's true for
100 years
all right so you got what
45 left right so here's the thing
you have to make this choice
do i want to live however many years i
got left
teeter-tottering on this relationship
should i stay should i go or i'm
gonna am i gonna cash everything in and
go all in and here's what go all in
means
go all in means i'm going to be
vulnerable
and vulnerability is like if you go look
up vulnerable
vulnerable in the dictionary it means
exposed
and exposed means i'm it's like i have a
little puppy right now and that little
puppy when she's wrestling with mother
dog will
when things get really tense she'll just
roll over on her back she is exposed
that big dog could bite a hole in her
tummy and it would be all she wrote for
that puppy dog
right so exposed means i'm opening
myself
up to the possibility of being hurt
again and that's what a marriage is
that's what a relationship is
i am going to put all my cards on the
table
i'm going to be vulnerable i'm going to
tell you i love you and i'm still
struggling and then what you're going to
do is you're going to
give yourself an opportunity to be fully
fully loved by this guy
but here's the other edge of that sword
you're going to give yourself an
opportunity for him to say
i don't love you like that and i'm out
right
right and so here's the thing and that
that pushed me forward
yeah well it's it's not so much you
don't need to push forward you just need
to make a decision am i
all in and all in means at some point
somebody's got to go first
do i think it should be you no but he's
not going to so it has to be
right right right you are
right so what i want you're at i can
hear in your heart you're at
you're at a breaking point right you're
at a it's got a it's got to be something
other than this either i gotta
just sit down on this lawn chair and say
this is the bait i'm gonna fish with
or i'm gonna cut the line and i'm gonna
start over and nobody wants to start
over at 55 but i'm telling you what you
don't want to be 70
or 62 and have wife number five pop
along you don't want to be
62 and have the old demons of abuse come
back without having gone all in and had
a conversation about how are we gonna
live this thing differently
a friend of mine um she was in her
second marriage
in fact she was a wonderful wonderful
person she told me something
in you know it gave me a reference point
for being a late life
second marriage that i just loved here's
what she said
she said i'm not going to build a
another life with somebody i did that i
was with somebody we
raised kids we moved from the starter
home to the other home and we had a car
and we wrecked a car we did all that
stuff
we built a life and then he passed away
and so what she her the way she shifted
her
her view of the second marriage right
and she was 50 55
the way she shifted that view was i'm
gonna have somebody
in my life and we are going to have more
fun
we're gonna take ev burn every bit of
tread off these tires
until we're done until it's all over
so they are at the lake every week they
are
laughing and smiling and carrying on and
dealing with each other's
arthritis and whatever stuff comes up
and they drop off each other at the
doctor's appointments
they have a totally different view they
are not trying to recreate the notebook
they are trying to
love one another and have a blast
and that starts with a conversation
right patty
that starts with you having this
conversation here's how i want it to go
i want you to let your husband know hey
we're going to have
a dti it's what the kids uh no dtr
that's right that's what the kids call
it we're going to define the
relationship
and he's going to look at you cross-eyed
because if you were my wife i'd look at
you i don't know what that
means honey we're going to have a dtr
it's what the kids are doing honey
and then i want you and him this is old
school deloney i want y'all to go get
breakfast together and i want you to
tell them
i'm going all in it's been a couple of
years
it's been a year two years since you
came back
i've hedged my bets you hurt me in the
past you know that we
we we're not gonna go all over that
again
you have healed from your abusive past
you've quit drinking so much i'm
trusting you that you're not cheating on
me anymore
and i'm ready to go all in here's what
that's gonna look like and i'm being
vulnerable here
you can really hurt me right now so be
gentle
but i want you to love me like crazy
i want you to get up early every once in
a while make me breakfast
and i want you to tell me that i'm
beautiful i want you to tell me
that you're so glad that i'm waking up
in the bed next to you
even when my breath stinks even when my
hair looks great
all of that and i want you to
love me like this and patty you deserve
that conversation you deserve
that sort of marriage
and my hope hope hope is that he looks
at you and his eyes tear up and he says
oh patty i'm all in
and he says i was embarrassed and
ashamed for how i treated you in the
past and i've been struggling to come
back
and now that i hear that you're all in
i'm all in too baby i'm all in
and here's what that's going to look
like
but just keep one eye open because
here's what could happen
he could say i'm not i'm not going to do
that and then you're going to have a
decision to make but at least you know
right now you're drowning in ambiguity
and at least you'll know
so um while we're here thank you so much
for that call patty
i'm grateful for you i really want to
know how that conversation goes
and i want to know what the next steps
and hey before i leave this patty i got
to just say this
so many folks i talk to all like day
after day after day
i just want to know what god wants me to
do i just i met with a pastor and i just
what am i supposed to do i've been
thinking about these things i just don't
know what to do i just
just take a step just take a step
we get so paralyzed by what's the next
step we get so paralyzed by what
god is asking us to do he is so
paralyzed by fill in the
just take the next step and know that
love and trust are things you practice
titanic
lied to us the notebook lied to us
you just got to practice it and then you
got to negotiate what that even looks
like together and that starts with that
vulnerable conversation
again while we're here um let's talk
real quick
the hardest thing about moving past
infidelity is twofold number one
you lose trust in somebody else right
they violated
your core values you said you would be
there you said i was the only one
and you violated that and
when someone cheats on you when someone
violates your your covenant
you lose trust in yourself why did i not
see this coming how could i have been
with somebody who was going to be like
that i should have known
now i don't trust anything every time he
says he's going to the store i just
think oh who's he with every time she
says hey i'm just going to the gym i
just like a who she with
and you just make yourself nuts right
so here's the thing infidelity tells
us a lie which is you're replaceable
well that's not really lie technically
you are right technically somebody can
walk in and say you know what you
weren't the one for me i'm out
that's so scary and so we at the when
you're thinking about coming back from
infidelity you got to remember
every relationship starts with risk not
with certainty
with risk if it's all guaranteed
man there's no desire there if it's all
guaranteed there's no
passion there that's like a relationship
with a math teacher
like i know she's going to be there i'm
going to be there
right my business professor my law
professor i know she's going to be there
i'm going to be there
man that's not that's not a a
a deep powerful strong covenant marriage
relationship right
so if you're going to stay with somebody
after infidelity
right i don't tell people to get
divorced except in very rare situations
here's the deal if you decide i'm gonna
stay
you gotta be all in you can't go part
ways in and i know that sets you up to
get hurt again
and that's like swimming upstream right
you can get hurt again you can drown
because you're going back in that same
lake
if you decide you want to forgive to
stay to re
build you've got to do just that rebuild
something new you can't go
back to what was right so patty you're
not trying to reclaim what happened
before
you found your husband's stuff on the
phone you're not trying to reclaim
what once was you're building something
new
whether you're 25 45 55 85
you're building something new you've got
to look at it like we're building a new
tower together
we're not going to sweep up all the old
dust and ash and glass and twist the
metal and try to rebuild it with that
materials nope
we're going to excavate that site we're
going to build something new and we're
going to do it together
and i see it all the time when someone
says i'm going to stay with them
i'm going to stay with that woman but
they only stay part ways
and you're just shooting a hole in the
lifeboat if you're going to be all in
you're going to be all in
you're going to have to get a couple of
friends who are going to walk alongside
you because it's
hard to rebuild trust you're going to
have to have people you can reach out to
you're probably going to need a marriage
counselor to walk you through this
if you ask any marriage counselor worth
their assault what's one of the most
common
and less worrisome things you can work
back from they'll tell you infidelity
marriage counselors are not scared of
couples coming back from that because
they do it all the time but they both
have to decide we're both all
in we're going to address the underlying
issues we're going to get to the root of
some of these challenges
and then we're going to build something
new we're going to be all in you can
do it thank you so much for that call
patty i'm grateful for you
i look forward to hearing how that call
went let's go to uh will
in florence what's up will how can i
help
hey how are you doing today i'm good
brother good hey thank you for taking my
call i really appreciate it you bet man
so what's up
all right so i would love to hear your
perspective and get your advice
on how i can help my younger brother out
he's
having a lot of trouble uh just really
getting his life together
and uh it's not it doesn't really listen
to what other people are saying would
love to hear your perspective
give me a little more information if he
doesn't listen to you this is a pretty
short call
because i'll just tell you yeah he won't
listen to you man um so
like what is your role what is your
influence in in his life and what is he
struggling with
sure so in in the past he's had a very
wild
lifestyle you know like all the drugs
and
um you know lots of different people
sleeping around
stuff like that yep um and she sounds a
lot like jen's
child's a lot like james back in the
booth yeah
and he's um he says he's moved on from
that
but he's never really moved forward if
that makes sense so he's having trouble
holding on to a job and
um he uh so like he'll have a stressful
day at work
and say well that was a stressful day so
i need to take the next week off and you
know there's the
you can't hold on to a job and so he uh
is just really having trouble moving
forward we have a a good relationship
and he
says like he really looks up to me and
and he
um my opinion means a lot to him and
and so i try to help him out and give
him coaching and
he knows all of the right things to say
um so i always uh for the last several
years
like i'll i'll talk to him about
something and say okay here's a plan
here's what we can do to get you in a
better place and and he'll say all the
right things that i feel
encouraged and and then he just doesn't
doesn't do it
you know how old is this um and uh he's
25.
um and so all of this kind of came to a
head um
a few well maybe a couple weeks ago now
he texted me at like midnight and was
just like i just want to die man i just
i just can't do this anymore and
um you know and i was trying to talk to
them and
um and calm them down and i said well
you know are
are you are you wanting to hear what you
know what i have to say this time
because not
i don't want to hear it and so he just
he was like i just want to get stuff off
my chest so i think he's
you know he it's like he wants to listen
but he knows
he's not going to do it either you know
it's like he'll he knows the right
things to say but he's just not going to
do it
are you in a place where you can meet
with him in person
yes okay so
i'm gonna break your heart and then
you're going to
i'm gonna give you some tools okay
um truth is you can't help your brother
other than connecting with them and
letting them know that you love him
he doesn't need another plan he doesn't
need another
routine it's not because he doesn't have
the right planner
it's not because the right background
music isn't playing during his workout
it's none of those things
what the the behavior you're talk you're
telling me about tells me there's a
history of demons there
some of which you probably know from
your childhood together some of which
you probably have no idea about
and dude he needs a brother that's going
to love him and it's going to hold him
accountable and it's going to love him
and it's going to love him
and sometimes that love means you know
where i'm at
sometimes that love means if you and so
here so that's the hard part
right you can't help him he's not
missing a plan
okay he's gonna have to make some
decisions on his own
in concert with community that he says
i'm gonna
i'm gonna make a run of this and i'm
gonna i'm gonna be whole
i think he'll come around because he's
got a big brother that loves him like
crazy
what he needs more than your judgment
right now is your connection
and here's what that's going to look
like okay
i don't want you to bring up his past
with him anymore
if he wants to talk about some some
things decisions he made in the past
that he doesn't agree with
great i don't want that to be a part of
your conversation with him anymore
i want you to love him right now and
love him for where he's going not for
the things
that he's done okay he carries that
shame around enough he doesn't need it
the second thing is i want you to get
with him in person and i want you to
tell him
i don't know how often you say this you
may say this all the time a lot of
brothers don't but i want you to look
them in the eye and say i need you to
hear me say these words
i love you and i'm glad i'm your brother
i will be here for you always
i'm here and if you
ever threaten to hurt yourself i'm
calling in
everybody i'm calling 9-1-1 i'm calling
mom and dad i'm calling
any i don't know grade school teachers
i'm calling everybody in the fire
department the neighbor i'm calling in
everybody
because that's over my ability to help
you and it scares me and i'm not going
to lose my brother
and i want you to let him know when he's
ready
you're going to continue to text him
you're going to continue to
leave voicemail messages on his machine
you're going to write him letters
you're going to continue to let him know
he's tethered in
but until he comes to you and knocks on
your door and says hey i'm ready for
some a plan i'm ready for some
accountability help me out here
he's just going to continue to leave
interactions with you
filled with shame because he's not you
he's going to leave interactions with
you exhausted because he can't do the
things big brother will's doing
okay and i know this is hard i know it
is
but at the end of the day you have to
draw boundaries around yourself
he's gonna have to make some hard hard
decisions and
man there are a few things more powerful
than a brother who loves another brother
right but nobody who i love gets to
threaten suicide without me calling in
everybody i know
nobody around me who um i love
is gonna not know that i don't love them
right
i don't know if i just said that the
right way i'm gonna let them know that i
love them that's what i'm saying will
okay and i'm also gonna let them know
i'm not gonna judge you anymore
i'm not gonna try to force things on you
i'm just gonna be here and i'm gonna be
thinking about you every single stinking
day
i'm gonna pray for you i'm gonna always
answer the phone when you call
but that's the best i can do and will
i'm telling you right now he needs
connection he needs people who are not
going to
say well you know if he needs love love
and connection and that's that's that
right so thanks for that call man i do
want to know how that conversation goes
will
i want to know how it goes and it's best
had in person it's best had planned
have it let him know that he's loved
maybe this
i'm gonna i'm gonna add an addendum
write him a letter and give it to him
after that
um at that breakfast at that lunch you
have with him
write him a letter and hand it to him so
we can take it home and read it and read
it and reread it
and i don't want it to mention anything
about the past i don't want to mention
anything about i can't believe the
decisions you're making none of that
i want to be short and to the point i
love you i'm
so glad i'm your brother i'm so glad i'm
your brother
and i love you love you love you and
when you
ever need anything i'm here love will
that's it
that's it everybody needs a brother like
will
put the judgment down start connecting
man all right let's take one more call
let's go to glen in dayton ohio glenn
what's up brother how can i help
hey john thanks so much for taking my
call i appreciate it you bet man
what's going on so we are really excited
our 21 year old son is getting married
this july
to his fiancee very cool and she's
finishing up her education degree
at a private college and he works
part-time and is training to be a
firefighter emt
at a local community college very cool
right now he's he's living with us
okay um so this is my question we are
discussing having them live in our home
for a fixed time so they can attack
their debt
and save money for a down payment they
would have a separate living space in
our finished basement
and we just have to do a couple things
like finish a bathroom for them
so my question to you is this is this a
good idea
or is this a bad idea so
i nor historically would have said
terrible idea never do this
i have someone who i consider a close
mentor to me someone who i go to for
wisdom right so he's a person i call um
has done this with his son
and daughter-in-law and it has been
extraordinary
okay and so i have to refine my original
position on this
so here's a couple of things i would
tell you you got a pin or actually you
can just watch this thing but here's
what i would recommend okay
but before i recommend anything number
one i just want to tell you thank you
for loving your kids and trying to give
them a head start
like your heart is awesome man and
man good for you glenn and not only that
it's that kind of heart that led to your
son to make great decisions about
who his future partner is going to be
about a guy who's
going to dedicate his life to serving
other people right that's that's the
kind of
kind of man you raised that's the kind
of home he's going to create so
man um you judge a tree bites by its
fruit man so congratulations clint this
is awesome
all right so here's what i want you to
do are you married
i am okay 30 years man good grief that's
awesome
listen people model it and it just
happens i'm telling you okay
so glenn i want you to get with your
wife and i want you to
listen to one another's fantasy about
what this is going to be like
and there's going to be a great picture
both of you have of what this is going
to be like and here's what it's going to
be
it's going to be this romanticized
picture the lights are going to be a
little bit
um dimmed not in a gross weird way but
y'all are going to have dinners together
and you're going to
laugh and he's going to look into her
eye and
to his his new wife's eye and she's
gonna look at his eye and
you and your wife are gonna smile
because it's beautiful and none of that
is gonna happen that way
okay that's right they're gonna move in
and not want to hang out with you at all
and they you're gonna hear some noi when
the basement
at glenn's house is a rocking we are not
coming knock
right all of that's going to be there
you so i want you and your wife to
to hear each other's fantasy about this
is going to be like and then y'all are
going to have to get down to the brass
tacks
okay so here's a couple of things i
would recommend
having something in writing and tell
your son i love you and
well i'm gonna pretend and you can just
tell them this is to protect everybody
some idiot on the radio suggested this
so let's just all do it so we're all on
the same page we're all
way above board so there's no confusion
so here's the um here's the thing
here's the rules of engagement for our
place okay
whatever those may be if you don't want
people coming and going at 2 am
let them know that up front okay if you
don't care they're married why would i
care he's got a job she's got a job i
don't care when they're coming and going
they can come to the side door in the
basement awesome put that
out there into the world i don't care
when y'all come and go son okay
that way there's not that weird thing
where he's like hey it's almost 10. we
got it back to my parents house and then
his wife starts resenting him and you
and
does that make sense so clarify those
types of things
i don't care when the trash is coming in
does that make sense yeah so basically
what i hear you saying is that
communication is absolutely going to be
key and that's really kind of my heart
um my biggest fear i guess is uh ruining
any future relationships he's
our third kid out of four so i get i
understand the concept that they're not
going to want to hang around with us so
i get all that
um and and we're all about privacy we
remember our first year
so we want to give that all to them
right but so what i hear you saying is
basically communicate in advance
before we do anything at all and i would
say explicitly communicate
right so bullet point it right and and
i don't say a business arrangement but
almost a tenant relationship
okay right then the second thing is is
plan a regular check-in breakfast
a regular check-in time together that
way it's on the calendar and it's not
weird
and you can say i'm practicing being a
landlord son
how are things going and he can say man
y'all are really annoying dad
whatever give him permission you can be
silly about it but set up regular
intervals
that way if there's any tension any
conversation needs to be had
there's not that added pressure on how
am i gonna approach dad it's already on
the calendar we're already gonna meet
once a month right
hopefully y'all are going to set up you
know sunday breakfast together or
something like that where you'll be
interacting with one another anyway
and then have an end date and you can
tell them we'll revisit this as we get
here but
we're going to do this for six months
and um we're gonna
this isn't gonna be indefinite but put
something on paper give them a plan to
work towards
and then as you get to month four and
five as part of your regular meeting
time you can say
all right where are we at how are we
doing and he can say man if we had three
more months it would change everything
feel free to extend it then but you
don't want each other feeling like
i'm gonna move out i don't know i'm
gonna get these idiots out of here right
all of that is just once there's a plan
and it's clear
simple and then the last thing is
don't make anything weird does that make
sense
like i know it's your house but you're
gonna have to just wear pants for the
next for the foreseeable future right
you're gonna have to mow your lawn not
in crocs and socks
like just wear regular shoes man you
know what i'm saying or
um don't make you know if you do
hear you know the basement rocking don't
saturday morning be like so kids
what was left don't be that guy you know
what i mean right of course make your
joke that joke with your wife and your
other kids for sure
but not just with him right and um
that's
if i'm talking to the there's a pot
talking to the kiddo that'd be so
so hard for me because i'd want to make
jokes because i would think it's awkward
and then
my way of getting out awkward is making
jokes and that just makes everything
worse
um but here's the thing i have a
thousand percent confidence
based on the son you raised
the wonderful woman he's marrying the
way you and your wife have set
this up that it's going to be a you are
inviting them in man that's awesome
lay good ground rules can over
communicate bullet point this stuff
tell your son you're practicing a tenant
relationship let him know that
set up regular intervals for when you're
going to have conversations
and man invite them to breakfast invite
them to dinner don't get your feelings
if they don't come
then you get to have fun in the
relationship part because you get to
anchor in it's going to be great
so good for you glenn man he's lucky to
have you and he's lucky that you're
thinking through this crap before
it is month three they're annoying
they're sloppy and messy
and they're coming and going at all
hours of the night and your wife's like
get them out and you're like i don't
know how
so wise that you're doing this on the
front end good for you all right so as
we wrap up today's show
the greatest song
ever ever and i've said ever before but
i've never said four evers
forever ever ever that's four evers
right and it's not sorry miss jackson
it is this 1999
what how old was i i was about to
graduate
then a guy playing a piano put some
beats behind it and recorded a record
his fourth album and i think he recorded
in his apartment
if i understand he came out with a
masterpiece
and it's off the white ladder album
david gray he's so cool he didn't need a
band name he's like i'm gonna name it
after myself
david gray wrote the song in babylon and
it goes like this
friday night i'm going nowhere all the
lights are changing green
to red turning over tv stations
situations running through my head
looking back through time you know it's
clear that i've been blind
i've been a fool to open my heart to all
that jealousy that bitterness that
ridicule
but if you want it come and get it
crying out loud the love that i was
giving you was never in doubt let go
your heart let go your head
and feel it now that feels good let go
of your heart let go of your head and
feel it now
babylon i don't know why he ends the
song with babylon but it just sounds
awesome
that's what happens when you name your
own band after yourself david greg way
to go this has been
the dr john deloney show
[Music]
you